50 ans plus tard la photo est toujours
difficile à regarder il y a cinq enfants
et des soldats mais c'est l'expression
de douleur de la jeune fille brûlée qui
attire toute l'attention
la scène se passe aux abords de 30
bagnes un village situé à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de Saigon au
moment d'un bombardement américain la
photo portait le titre la terreur de la
guerre mais elle est vite devenue la
fillette ou napalm dans l'esprit
populaire
à l'âge adulte qu'il me faut qui a
réussi à fuir le Vietnam et à obtenir le
statut de réfugié au Canada où elle a
refait sa vie elle est devenue
ambassadrice de bonne volonté pour
l'UNESCO à l'époque la photo de l'agence
la société de presse avait fait le tour
du monde publié en Une de tous les
grands journaux alors on sent vraiment
qu'on est dans un moment
instantané ou il y a plus rien qui tient
là c'est c'est une photo difficile à
regarder mais qui est nécessaire selon
moi le photographe de Radio-Canada il va
nous deux mers récipient d'air de
nombreux prix de photos journalistes se
demandent si cette photo serait diffusée
aussi largement aujourd'hui je serais
curieux de voir comment qu'elle serait
traitée est-ce qu'il y aurait des gens
qui auraient tendance à brouiller des
images la jeune fille étendue je suis
pas certain que tous les maisons
publieraient cette image là aujourd'hui
il va nous demeure tu crois qu'une photo
de guerre a encore aujourd'hui le
potentiel d'éveiller prenez conscience
c'est une famille au Québec qui est
touchée puis qui décide c'est du quoi
moi je vais accueillir des réfugiés
Ukrainiens à la maison ben on aura fait
notre travail
qu'il me faut quand on a longtemps voulu
au photographes unique août d'avoir
publié cette image qui a transformé sa
vie elle se sentait méprisée le corps
mutilé par la bombe incendiaire pourtant
après avoir pris ses photos le
journaliste l'avait emmené à l'hôpital
ce qui lui avait sauvé la vie il a
toujours gardé le contact avec elle et
elle appelle aujourd'hui on clique
la petite fille au napalm a aujourd'hui
59 ans elle se dit fière d'être devenue
un symbole de paix en cette période
perturbée
Sylvain Desjardins Radio-Canada Montréal